Este martes la vicepresidenta de
Argentina Cristina Fernández habló por
última vez en un juicio en el que se le
investiga por presunta corrupción en un
discurso difundido en directo desde el
senado acusó a la corte de ser un
tribunal de guerra jurídica debo decir
que esto más que un tribunal de
fui muy generosa creo en realidad es un
verdadero pelotón de fusilamiento la
vicepresidenta está acusada de haber
cometido delitos de asociación ilícita y
administración fraudulenta de fondos
públicos el fiscal llegó luciani la
señala de estar inmersa en un auténtico
sistema de corrupción institucional y
describe el caso como la mayor operación
de corrupción que ha visto el país
señalamientos que Fernández de kirchner
siempre negó acusando los fiscales de
mentir y deformar los hechos se demostró
que todos y cada uno de las cosas que
había sido acusación del fiscal eran
mentiras la vicepresidenta podría
enfrentar una pena de hasta 12 años de
prisión y la prohibición de ser elegida
en cargos públicos de por vida la
decisión final de los jueces se espera
para el próximo 6 de diciembre durante
el juicio sus opositores se reunieron
frente al tribunal de justicia de Buenos
Aires
hace mucho que estamos esperando una
condena de aquellos que nos han robado
el futuro al mismo tiempo algunos de sus
partidarios estaban frente al senado sea
lo que sea para mí es inocente yo voy a
estar apoyando a mi candidata no vamos a
permitir que la meta empresa el primero
de septiembre pasado la ex mandataria
sufrió una atentado fallido después de
que un fiscal solicitará su condena por
presunta corrupción un hecho que deja
tres detenidos